so what did you want to talk about
when spring comes I'm leaving town I'm
going to Midgar I'm gonna be a soldier
[Music]
the best of the best like Sephiroth
[Music]
tell me
is it really human
are we on schedule please mr. president
I am asking you to reconsider no begging
director to restate the stench of the
directors cowardice fills the room yet
again motto supersaturation confirmed
engaging materially to reduce
temperature at am director you have a
meeting shortly stop
your timing is impeccable atrocious oh
dear oh dear
a man of my refined tastes running out
of butter
welcome to the honeybee and true beauty
is an expression of the heart a thing
without shades
- which notions of gender don't apply
perfection not a word not even one no
but you're so pretty
today's right to be seen pathetic which
one of you said that
you got a mouth on you well aren't we
having a wonderful time kicking the
hornet's nest you know what I want a
second day just the few of us so what
the hell is it
a fascinating question did it talk I am
that what you see before you nothing
a touching reunion
very very good and thus is a hypothesis
proven correct I can only hope you will
continue not to disappoint come on
avalanche a new tower anybody's [ __ ]
we're here to rescue Aaron remember we
don't need more attention than what
we're gonna get yeah
[Music]
I know these people and I know they're
never gonna let Eric go she's the last
living ancient on a planet think about
what that means to Shinra scientists
this is the source of everything to Nova
[Music]
this General Electric Power Company
isn't the real enemy
promise you there's a much bigger threat
I just want to do everything
I would help all of you and the planet
[Music]